Speaker 1: Fox News has been regularly bringing
on a so-called invasion expert to give his
analysis of what's going on in the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and oops.
Lo and behold, it turns out that the guy is
a Trump appointed Putin propagandist.
This guy's name is Douglas MacGregor.
Douglas McGregor has appeared with Tucker
Carlson and all.
He's all over Fox News as a so as a so-called
expert on the invasion.
And it turns out he's one of these sort of
Putin defenders who at one point was actually
appointed by Donald Trump.
Listen to this.
This is a very good article from Rolling Stone
outlining the entire thing, which says Trump
at one point nominated considered a McGregor
for a number of different jobs ultimately
nominated him.
To be the U.S. ambassador to Germany, ultimately,
the nomination didn't pan out when CNN reported
on McGregor's history of racism.
Trump was undeterred, appointing McGregor
as a Pentagon senior adviser shortly after
the 2020 election.
This guy is a bonkers pro-Putin guy.
OK, let's look at some clips.
Here he is arguing against sanctions, basically
saying the sanctions are futile.
It's not going to hurt.
It's not going to hurt Putin.
It's not going to hurt Russia.
Speaker 2: It's the sanctions, as you rightly
point out, will do a lot of damage to us.
They're not going to make much difference
to Russia.
China will stand with Russia.
It knows it has to.
Russia has an abundance of food and energy.
China will take it all now.
Speaker 1: Everything he said.
There is wrong.
He's the guy is just wrong, number one.
Although initially, Russia said, we don't
care about the sanctions, they're not doing
anything to us.
Russia later conceded, actually, the sanctions
are very damaging and painful, and it even
led to Putin putting nuclear elements of nuclear
deterrence on higher alert.
So it was wrong that Russia would not be impacted
by the sanctions and the number two, this
idea that China will never, ever, ever do
anything, anything, anything against Russia
in the last 24 hours.
China has started for the first time, referring
to what Russia has done in Ukraine as an invasion
and as a war.
And this is not something that they previously
had done.
So even on that, he is wrong as well.
Next clip McGregor went on Fox News, this
time with Stuart Varney, and said the Russian
Army is actually it's been too gentle, but
now it's going to get everything done within
10 days.
He called Zelensky a delusional puppet, and
he said that all of the Ukrainian claims about
what's going on are propaganda.
Wow.
All of that is also false.
Speaker 2: The first five days Russian forces,
I think, frankly, were too gentle.
They've now corrected that, so I would say
another 10 days.
They should be completely over.
But the question is what is it?
Did Zelensky is going to do?
The Russians have made it very clear what
they want is a neutral Ukraine.
This could have ended days ago if he accepted
that, and then
Speaker 1: they could it guys.
If only Zelensky accepted the invasion, this
would have ended a long time ago.
Speaker 2: Just the borders.
But the eastern part of Ukraine is firmly
in Russian hands.
Speaker 1: By the way, when he says adjust
the borders, he's saying allow Russia to steal
the land.
Speaker 2: But again, the Russians are not
seizing territory.
They're destroying Ukrainian forces.
That's their focus, colonel.
It sounds like you don't approve of Zelensky
stand.
Oh, I think Zelensky is a puppet, and he is
putting huge numbers of his own population
at unnecessary risk.
And quite frankly, most of what comes out
of Ukraine is debunked as lies within 24 to
48 hours.
Speaker 1: That's also completely untrue.
And once again, he said that it was only going
to be 10 more days.
He said this back on March 4th or fifth, which
means within five or six days, according to
this expert on invasions, Russia should have
taken Ukraine.
My prediction is that will not have happened
five to six days from now and then.
Lastly, here he is saying we got to stop demonizing
Putin.
Come on,
Speaker 2: do not want to do in our usual
effort to demonize him and his country.
We need to remember that Ukraine is forced
from the bottom of one hundred and fifty eight
countries in the world as corrupt.
Russia is perhaps three or four places above
them.
This is not the liberal democracy now.
Speaker 1: I don't know what he's citing there,
but as many of you know, in multiple serious
democracy indices, Ukraine ranks much higher
in democracy than Russia.
Speaker 2: Shining example that everyone says
it is far from it.
Mr Zelensky has jailed journalists and his
political opposition.
I think we need to stay out of it.
The American people think we should stay out
of it.
The Europeans think we should stay
Speaker 1: out of it.
Now that's also not true.
The American people, although there, they
don't want to commit troops, and I agree with
that.
The American people think we should be arming
and supporting Ukraine.
I mean, you can you can say that that's wrong.
But what MacGregor is saying is just completely
incorrect.
He is the wrong guest man.
You know how Alex Berenson is the wrong biggest
man in America on COVID?
McGregor seems to be the wrong biggest man
in America, on Russia, Ukraine, and Fox continues,
bringing him on as an expert when he's really
just a Putin propagandist who couldn't even
get the position Trump selected him for because
of his outrageous, racist past that came out.
We'll have these clips that I played on our
Instagram at David Pakman show if you want
to check them out